our leaders are stupid our politicians
are stupid
donald trump who four short years ago
was viewed by many gop
operatives as an erratic outsider has
just been renominated as the party's
standard bearer
but whether he wins or loses can a party
without any guiding principles survive
how do old political parties die and how
are new ones born
imagine a political party that has lost
its ideological coherence and is torn
apart by various warring factions then
an outsider
and celebrity candidate emerges with no
fealty to the party's policy agenda and
with
no previous political experience he goes
on to connect with voters
and retake the white house that's
exactly what happened
in 1848 when the whigs backed zachary
taylor
political scientist philip wallach a
resident senior fellow at the think tank
the r street institute published a 2017
paper
on the parallels between taylor and
trump he was a very disruptive force
for the whig party his victory was of
course something they
were very excited about but he didn't
govern in exactly the ways they would
have preferred
[Music]
son of freedom taylor was very much an
outsider to the whig party
he had not spent any of his life in
professional politics he was a soldier
bringing in somebody who has not been
conditioned to be part of the
political machinery always has the
potential for
big disruptions while trump raised his
profile by projecting a bellicose
demeanor on primetime television
i work hard you've been lazy you've been
nothing but trouble
you're fired taylor was a celebrated
general who won a key battle in the
mexican-american war
and like trump he tried to redefine his
party in his own image
and refused to pledge fealty to party
principles
donald trump refused to rule out a third
party run if he's not the nominee
mr trump taylor sought to position
himself
as being above the fray while at the
same time trying to sort of reshape
what the whig coalition might have been
he even thought about rebranding it as
taylor republicanism
but taylor's efforts at redefining whig
principles
were doomed by a pre-existing divide
over whether slavery would be allowed
in new territories both the whigs and
their opponents the democrats waffled
which
generated electoral momentum for
single-issue third parties such as the
abolitionist liberty party
and anti-slavery free soil party as well
as the nativist no-nothing party
after taylor's untimely demise the
fractured wig party
bled to death as historian michael hulk
put it losing
too many voters to the single issue free
soil and no nothing parties
and out of that carnage rose the
republican party
united by the conviction that slavery
should have no part in america's future
so what does the death of the whigs tell
us about the prospect of breaking up our
modern two-party duopoly
we have two parties that have delivered
us candidates
both of which are more destructive
than they are constructive the
evolutionary biologist and podcast host
brett weinstein sees a parallel with the
mid-19th century in that voters are
again
open to alternatives this is in some
sense the natural
outgrowth of the fact that the parties
long ago
stopped serving the interests of the
american public weinstein who's best
known for his viral confrontation with
student protesters at evergreen state
college
after he objected to a call for all
white people to leave campus for a day
believes that the two major parties are
enthralled to far left and far right
fringes
and elite donors causing them to neglect
a majority of americans
our policy has moved so far from serving
the average american citizen that we can
agree on a tremendous amount that needs
to be done
in order to serve average americans
before we get to the things about which
we substantially disagree
so for many reasons the natural thing
is for americans to unify under some
banner
in order to regain power over the policy
making
structure weinstein launched an
initiative called unity 2020
which will use online crowdsourcing to
nominate a center-left and center-right
candidate to run and govern as a team
he says by circumventing the usual
political process
candidates will avoid being so easily
corrupted
we have all been told that power tends
to corrupt and absolute power corrupts
absolutely and therefore if we
award people great power we will
discover their corruption
i have long thought this is nonsense
what we do have is a system
in which power tends to be awarded to
people on the basis that they are
corruptable but in the 19th century
there were fewer obstacles to
challenging the major parties
for a third party to be able to get some
votes
was much easier it just had to be able
to print ballots and distribute them to
a network of
supporters in that way 19th century
politics were just much more open and
fluid
than our politics today with the
election less than two and a half months
away
unity 2020 released a slate of possible
candidates
but the ticket is unlikely to make it on
many ballots
and weinstein declined to articulate a
plausible path to victory
we are certainly too late with respect
to the standard process of collecting
signatures to get on the ballots
of all 50 states but that's not the only
way this can be accomplished what are
some of these other mechanisms you're
alluding to
we're not describing them because we
know that to describe them would quickly
trigger
those who have this stranglehold on
power to
work to block them it's really important
that we be on the ballot in all 50
states
because we need to give people a real
choice and what they have now
is not a real choice the libertarian
party presidential candidate joe
jorgensen is on track to getting on the
ballot in all 50
states and says she offers a better path
forward
than either trump or biden people are
realizing that they don't have the
choices that they used to have
and i think they're getting fed up with
government telling them
at every turn what they can do i'd say
the libertarian party
is kind of a confusing phenomenon to me
in many ways it doesn't really act like
a real political party at all it doesn't
really try to
field candidates across the whole
spectrum of offices
state and local as well as presidential
wallach is skeptical that a third party
can disrupt our modern duopoly
in the 19th century minor parties like
the free soilers won
local and state elections and
congressional seats which the
libertarian party has mostly failed to
achieve
in 2016 after getting more attention
than any libertarian candidate in
history
former new mexico governor gary johnson
won just over three percent of the
popular vote when going up against trump
and clinton
what do you say to people who are just
feeling really pessimistic about the
entire
project at this point well i'd like to
point out that we recently have our
first congressman with justin amash
so we are headed in the right direction
while it's true that
former republican justin amash became
the libertarian party's first sitting
member in congress
just three months after switching
parties he announced that he wouldn't
seek re-election
a third party or independent candidate
has never triumphed in a modern
presidential election
with the only strong contenders being
former president teddy roosevelt to run
under the progressive party banner
and the self-funded billionaire ross
perot in 1992 who eventually spun off
the reform party which never won an
election
but did become the site of donald
trump's first foray
into presidential politics we don't have
too much common sense in our government
that leaves us
wondering where would such a third party
come from
wallach says that based on the death of
the whigs to be successful libertarians
would need to win in statewide races and
then
merge with defectors from a collapsed
democratic or republican party
if for example the republican party were
going to split
into a more libertarian-ish wing versus
in a more populist wing
you would imagine that new
libertarianish wing saying
all of you weirdos who were supporters
of the libertarian party before you
welcome you with open arms into this
new true freedom party or whatever it
will be called
but weinstein is betting that digital
media has opened up
new channels for a unity ticket to
bypass traditional gatekeepers as
outsider candidate andrew yang did in
the democratic primary
andrew yang would potentially not have
gained our attention
had it not been for this alternative
media network
he certainly rose spectacularly in the
public imagination at the point he
showed up on joe rogan's program
and the very fact of joe rogan's program
tells us that there is
something of similar or greater
magnitude to the major networks that is
operating under a different set of rules
and while there's no single issue
dividing the nation that's on par
with slavery in the time of the whigs
weinstein does see historical parallels
the thing that caused the civil war is
simply not fully resolved
while weinstein is supportive of some
aims of the black lives matter movement
he believes its emphasis on racial
identity foments dangerous divisions for
different reasons but in similar ways as
do
racist movements on the far right we are
now seeing a movement that wishes to
place
race back at the forefront of our
political thinking
frighteningly that viewpoint seems to be
shared by those on the far
left and the far right we cannot remain
cohesive as a nation if we are attacking
each other on the basis that the only
thing we need to understand to know what
team we are on
is the color of our skin or our gender
it's the government that's created a lot
of this racism we all talk about the
rosa parks store and a heroic black
woman stood up and refused to sit in the
back of the bus
but what people don't realize is that
that was a government-run
government-owned bus and so it was the
government who was putting us
in this us versus them situation while
their strategies and analyses differ
weinstein and jorgensen both agree that
the status quo
cannot hold i see everything is at stake
in this particular
election and what we've been delivered
is two different failure modes when one
finds that
situation we have to look for a third
way and in this case
if it's considered radical so be it it's
simply
time americans are frustrated because
they don't have
any control over their own lives and
that's because
of the way this administration has
handled the chronovirus and you may have
heard the myth that oh
people don't like change actually it's
not the change that's difficult
it's the uncertainty right now we have a
lot more uncertainty than we used to
have
people in the 50s 60s 70s they could
afford to buy houses they could afford
to get married and have kids
and what we're seeing right now is
people feeling
as though they're not in control of
their own lives all they know is that
it's the two old parties that are making
them feel this way